je crois que c'est une question vraiment
intéressante parce que je crois que j'ai
les deux côtés chasseuse écueil au
dessus d'une chasse aux skyhawks quoi
qu'est-ce qu'elle échoue chante c'est
tout moi quoi henry sur rire là bon
écoute et on a presque fait tour l'a11
si oui lequel ce nouveau moteur
professionnels y en a beaucoup nous on
n'a pas senti des auberges en lice
m'oriente soleil les emmerdes
okola alice lumière son collant à les
focus focus focus
oh [ __ ] faut que je dise quand même là
non mais attends qu est ce qui me fait
ce qu'on l'a non non tu entends où la
quête une fête voilà c'est moi qui l'ait
vu en premier la alice nommée allissa
temps s'est éclairci tomates le cul tu
lui dis merci c'est ça la met va te
faire [ __ ] toi là fils de [ __ ]
oui merde elle me parle à aller coûte
alors on a posé une question là les
écoutes qui était allé concentre-toi
olaru écoute qu'elle te dit écoute on
aura mais non c'est parce que je me
parle dans ma tête parfois les aider
enfin bon allez au revoir on vous envoie
un mec merci beaucoup c'est super
vraiment écoutez moi je pense que j'ai
tout ce qu'il me faut vous ne demandez
pas si j'ai des questions
alors voici bien sûr ce que vous avez
des questions mais que je suis cru j'ai
complètement oublié de vous parler de ma
vie associative ça va vous intéresser ça
je vous connaissais la smr donc je m'en
foutais chat
alors bien finir par s'épuiser sous sol
tout comme une autre
quand ça faisait de la virtuelle le truc
sur un oui c'est ça ça venait de l'art
notamment super super qui utilise en
fait on se trompait stop stop stop
l'adieu de la poubelle oui oui pièce au
[ __ ] kiev c'est génial pardon j'ai ce
petit bitonio là qui traînent sur mon
bureau depuis des mois je sais pas ce
que c'est je me demande tout le temps ce
que c'est j'ose pas le jeter en disant
que si je le jette je vais trouver ce
que c'est hier je le jette
hier je viens de réaliser mais à ce
moment même vous savez elle va donner
quoi
pour une fois ils ont pas vider la
poubelle je suis pas content par voyez
ce que je veux dire bah oui moi moi
c'est pareil avec les mecs
en fait c'est quand je les ai perdus que
je me rends compte que bah il est utile
et ça suffit je lui dis que c'est fini
tu lui dis je veux plus voir ta gueule
dans la société met vraiment en plus
polis quoi aller la force tranquille
non non non et non mon propos c'est non
ok pas de souci
[ __ ] je le fais voilà
mario mario wii mario à banon et non pas
ça en fait